so my brother uh W part of the reason he
wins is the the president uh and he won
it twice in a row which is unusual I me
he was a good really remarkable kid and
uh he won it because he he pushed for
and got done a smoking Lounge nah-uh
yeah he got it he made it happen he made
it happen listen I talked about this on
this podcast I was a freshman in 1987
that's the last year we had a
smoking lounge and I asked my friends
like do you guys remember that and some
of them do and I'm like it was right on
the corner by the science rooms and it
was this one little room and you had to
either be 18 or your parents had to be
trash and sign a permission slip to say
that my 15y old can smoke
cigarettes that's interesting fought for
smoking he fought for a smoking Lou and
died of lung cancer I mean it's just
that's the definition of
irony the Honeydew with Ryan zler